[Musique]
c'est parti la fête va commencer au
théâtre de champ fleuri
devant un public impatient la nouvelle
programmation de la saison septembre
décembre du théâtre va être dévoilée la
promesse d'intenses moments d'arts de
cultures et de plaisir
[Musique]
les artistes présents ce mardi soir sont
fiers d'être du spectacle lens est super
agréable parce que c'était un projet
qu'on leur parle depuis plusieurs années
je rêvais de faire ce projet et 2
contres contemporain du coup c'est une
grande aventure
nous sommes très heureux oui parce que
c'est une reconnaissance de notre
travail
et puis l'écrin du théâtre plein air
c'est vraiment une scène pour nous qui
nous convient bien
moi je suis très très contente
d'attendre qu'il ya une très belle
programmation sur ce
cette nouvelle saison est très honorée
en fait un d'en faire partie capté 8
bien sûr surtout au festival total dans
ce jeu c'est un festival international
du coup
dans ce festival c'est déjà beaucoup de
choses pour moi c'est une programmation
encore une fois forte intense qui qui
fait encore la part belle aux artistes
réunionnais que ce soit musique danse ou
théâtre et aussi des artistes de
l'extérieur avec le retour du festival
de danse et comme d'habitude tu toujours
très très heureux très fier de pouvoir
poser une programmation aussi riche au
théâtre de champ fleuri au théâtre de la
mer et qui sont deux établissements
du département mais voilà donc m'y
encouragent de venir voir et à venir
découvrir la programmation et bien sûr
aux autres le spectacle qui fait pas mal
conservés fait du bien et donc venez
danser vivre pleurer rire chanter avec
nous ça va être juste énorme formidable
et les invités conte qui partagent ce
même enthousiasme
je trouve que c'est vraiment une très
très bonne première saison avec beaucoup
de diversité
beaucoup de choses différentes entre la
chanson spectacle les danses et je
trouve que c'est très important pour le
public
le programme est tellement riche que
faudrait que je m'inscrive tous les
jours un spectacle donc je vais être
obligé de sélectionner les spectacles il
ya quelque chose même de très important
qu a dit pascal tout à l'heure c'est que
les prix ici par rapport à ceux de
métropole moi qui avais qui regardent et
vécurent métropole émincer vraiment
avantageux et les spectacles présentés
vraiment là files d'attentes pour
réserver on dit déjà long sur la qualité
des spectacles proposés diffuser la
culture le savoir au travers de la danse
du théâtre du chant ou encore des arts
plastiques est une véritable mission de
service public
une mission que le conseil départemental
au nord au sein du théâtre
[Musique]